miles de migrantes centroamericanos
atraviesan el territorio mexicano
su objetivo alcanzar la frontera con
eeuu muchos menores viajan solos luego
que la elección de joe biden a la casa
blanca les diera esperanzas una ley de
protección infantil fue promulgada en
noviembre por el presidente mexicano en
un intento por mitigar el impacto
humanitario de la migración ésta prohíbe
la detención de menores en centros
migratorios y les ofrece un estatus
legal provisional pero la situación no
es fácil en estos centros hacen una ley
no los pueden detener hay mucho mucha
circulación de adolescentes y ahora pues
estamos viendo qué hacemos con ellos y
los tenemos aquí en casa ellos hay que
implementar algún albergue o zonas
también en toda la ruta migratoria en
donde se pueda iros quedando este grupo
de adolescentes y trabajar con ellos en
su reintegración social algunos señalan
que las decisiones de méxico y eeuu por
mejorar la situación han exacerbado la
crisis migratoria porque porque aumenta
el número de menores loa compañeros
porque las disposiciones legales tanto
de nuestro país como eeuu como es lógico
protegen a esos menores entonces no
puedes repartir a una persona que va con
un menor
pero después el adulto desaparece
la vicepresidenta de eeuu kamala harris
anunció que viajará pronto a mexico para
buscar la forma de lograr el desarrollo
económico de las naciones
centroamericanas para frenar la
migración los planes de la funcionaria
estadounidense fueron confirmados por el
presidente de guatemala alejandro
giammattei quien aseguró que
posiblemente se alcanzaran acuerdos en
materia migratoria durante la visita